-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"all I want for Christmas"
wishes from you guys.
Here we go.
This first from is
from @gingerbreadtho.
She says, "All I want for
Christmas is for Netflix
to stop making me feel bad
by asking,
'Are you still watching?'"
Yeah. I'm still watching
'cause I worked all day.
Leave me alone.
This one here is
from @Mikefaubert1.
He says, "All I want for
Christmas is to go back in time
and change my daughter's name
from Alexa to something else.
Literally anything else."
[ Applause ]
-Aw, come on.
-Beautiful name.
This one's from @dollarclown.
[ Laughter ]
He says, "All I want for
Christmas is for Jason Momoa
to just hook up with my wife
already
so I can stop hearing about it."
-Oh, wait!
[ Laughter ]
-He's everyone's hottie, man.
This one's from @jammiedior.
That's a cool name.
-That's a cool name.
-Jammie Dior.
I'd like to have a friend
like Jammie Dior.
Friend Steve, friend Dennis.
This is Jammie Dior.
[ Laughter ]
It's like a deejay.
-Yeah.
-DJ Jammie Dior.
[ Air horn ]
Yo, yo, yo.
-Bringing in the new year!
Dance instigator Jammie Dior!
-Uh, sorry, Jammie
couldn't make it.
She's very tired.
[ Laughter ]
She says, "All I want for
Christmas is hash browns
where every layer
is the crunchy layer."
-Yes!
-Yes! That is right, Jammie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love Jammie Dior.
This last one here
is from @thecanmancan.
He says, "All I want for
Christmas is for people
to stop clapping
when a plane lands.
It's what it's supposed to do!"
There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.